plus claire et plus spacieux les
visiteurs emprunteront désormais le
nouveau pavillon dufour pour accéder au
château de versailles
ce vendredi françois hollande l'a
inaugurée et salué cette réussite
esthétique des espaces qui sont à la
fois réussite esthétique
chacun ici a eu lieu la contempler et en
même temps aussi un exploit fonctionner
puisqu'il fallait devient dénaturé et en
même temps faire en sorte que le public
6 millions de visiteurs puissent être
encore mieux accueillis c'est en 2011
que le château de versailles a confié
ses travaux à l'architecte dominique
perrault tout en respectant l'histoire
du château des matériaux modernes ont
été ajoutés au pavillon pour le pavillon
dufour c'est un ensemble qui est 18e et
17e et l'intervention évidemment études
d'intervention contemporaine avec la
mise en place d'un grand escalier de
marbre qui va permettre à l'ensemble des
visiteurs de sortir
à l'issue de la visite pour les
rejoindre les jardins une boutique un
auditorium et des annexes se rajoute à
ce bâtiment de 2700 mètres carrés au
premier étage un café restaurant du chef
étoilé alain ducasse ouvrira en
septembre